[Music]
now mali's vice president has confirmed
he's ousted the prime minister and
president
and has stripped them of their power
colonel isimi goethe
who led a military coup last year
accuses the leaders of violating
transitional agreements
they're being held in a military
facility near the capital bamako
go to insist elections will take place
next year as planned
uh let's speak to our correspondent
nicolas hack who's following these
developments from senegal's capital
dhaka
and nick so the the military if if you
like snipped off the uppermost branches
of the government so what happens now
well that's right i mean critics of
what's happening say it looks like the
man that organized a coup
nine months ago we're talking here about
vice president asimi goita a colonel
in the special forces of the malian army
has organized a second coup nine months
later
um dismissing the civilian uh
government that he had himself put into
put in place
when uh president ibrahim kate
the former president was taken off of
power but in a statement
made on national television signed by
himself
and made by members of the military he
said
that essentially that the prime minister
was incompetent he he said that
prime minister 1 was incapable of being
a reliable intermediary
in discussions with trade unions trade
unions have been on strike for several
weeks now
because of unpaid wages he goes further
saying that there's been public
consternation about
the inability of this government of
transition to move
forward i mean there's been um enormous
demands
from the malian people for a return to
civilian rules and also for
elections to happen as soon as possible
right now the
president-election the presidential
elections are supposed to take place in
february 2022
and that's too late for many malians he
goes on saying that
you know a new government was put in
place
without his consultation and saying
therefore that he was in breach
of the charter of transition and
therefore he dismissed
both the prime minister and the uh
and and the president itself he's now
back in charge
if not he was already in charge and this
shows really
uh more than anything else nick that the
military are in charge of mali right now
now there's been a public outcry in
regards to what has happened there's
been
attempts to have protests on the streets
of bamako but security forces are
deployed and they've tried to
disperse uh those crowds nick
nicholas hack there in uh observing
events there from dhaka let's
speak to muhammad sallahu who's a
journalist and publisher
of lemalimag.com which is a news website
in mali and joins us via skype from the
capital
obamacare muhammad so colonel goethe
who led the military coup last year he
insisted elections will take place
next year as planned do you think they
will
yes assimi kaita
is the strongman of the former junta who
deposed the former elected
president ibrahimovacar keita
on august nine months ago
and asimi the same assimilta
sent today it's a communication advisor
on national tv
to broadcast a new statement and in
its this new statement it said that
the the vice president of the transition
who
is asimi guitar have passed
out of their prerogative the prime
minister
and the president of the transition uh
according to to assimi guitar those two
authorities have regulated the charter
of the transition contrary to the off
taken on
taken a few months ago when they
established
the charter of uh the transition right
muhammad what's what's been the response
on the street so what are what are
people saying what are people thinking
on the streets the response is over
because
malian mammalian people youth
are showing unhappiness regarding the
current situation
the way the militaries
took the president and the vice
president to
kathy just after the reshuffle
ministerial
uh where this uh unhappiness is for
it's when the the the defense minister
and the security minister
who are also two strong men of the junta
have not been appointed in the
government of
uh established by moktarwan and the
president
banda without consulting the vice
president of transition who is in charge
of security and defense
so the unhappiness is from that point
and malian
are showing also unhappiness regarding
the way
the the junta the military are doing
regarding the way
they arrest those two authorities uh
there are call
for protests in bamako to show that
people are not agree about military and
they want the military to release
the president and the vice president who
are still detained
in katie which which is a gorizon town
located in 15 kilometers of bamako okay
muhammad appreciate that muhammad
assalah
journalist and publisher of
limalimag.com